The team is calling this stupid. Why are you not on the team,
Hutch? The entire team is calling this stupid, man. Wake up.
The Nazi tattoo is nowhere near as bad. You bald [__]
Off. No. No. No. Fantasy. That didn't happen. Nope. It's not
a genocide.
All right. Do we want to get into this Hutch segment? So Hutch
watched or was about to watch a Kyle My whole life. >> This
is a video from Kyle Kolinsky on the backlash to voting for Platner.
This is a his oxen claus video. Yeah, his Aenclaus video. Okay,
we've talked about the subject already. Do any of are any of
you guys unaware of Jake Oenclaus, the Massachusetts House of
Representatives member who basically said he couldn't in good
conscious like vote for Graham Platner
and basically said that he wouldn't be able to do that and really
didn't keep it restricted to the primary and then came out later
and tried to walk it back to just being about the primary, but
it really wasn't about the primary. He was kind of saying forever.
That happened like 3 days ago. So, that's what the video is about
with Kyle. And we're going to watch Hutch go through it because
I do think
Hutch has effectively in in a lot of ways seemingly walked back
the blue no matter who thing to the uncommitted position
or at least one where he doesn't feel comfortable
criticizing the uncommitted position, which is insane.
Okay, given how much he's basically spent all of his time in
political advocacy for the past year and a half on people who
were uncommitted in 2024,
right? And now he's essentially getting to the point where he's
saying it's wrong to criticize these people. >> Check in
with Kyle Kolinsky again. We watched one of his videos yesterday,
but this is a topic that I think we should probably talk about
a little bit. So, there's a uh a Democrat
in Massachusetts
who came out and said that he doesn't think the party should
support Platiner.
We're technically still in a primary, but also the primary is
effectively over. And so, there's a lot of anger being directed
at this particular Democrat
for not being blue no matter who kind of a thing. Even though
technically we're still in the primaries, the conversation to
me is
necessary and important right now
I just think we need to be mindful of the optics.
Uh, and I think the optics of
>> of guilt tripping a man.
What are the optics of supporting anybody without even looking
into it? Supporting anybody who is still like an open and avowed
Zionist. What are the optics like there? Hutch
optics should be pretty bad there.
personally I feel like supporting all of the dying in Lebanon
right now is far far far worse.
And having a tattoo, a Nazi tattoo even. Are we really we're
going to hand ring over a Nazi tattoo when realistically this
is about Israel? It is again about Israel. That is what it's
going to be. Again, I do believe that's where Kyle's video goes.
Okay, man. It's
>> over not wanting to support a candidate who had a Nazi
tattoo. Like the optics are so bad.
Um, when
Rashida Talib didn't endorse Kamla,
I told my chat at the time and I meant that. I'm like, I'm not
gonna give her for that. you know, I'm just I I'm not, you know,
she has family in Gaza, so it's a really emotionally charged
kind of issue for her.
And, you know, is it really the end of the world if she didn't
endorse?
I caution people against that kind of stuff because it's like,
you know, it's just the optics are not great. Um, that was a
really kind of tough pitch
during the the Biden campaign and the Kala campaign, but it's
the same kind of logic here. Like, I don't think we should be
up in arms calling for the resignation of a Democrat because
he's uncomfortable endorsing a guy who had a Nazi tattoo for
like 15 years and definitely at some point became aware that
it was a Nazi tattoo. He's just
Hutch. Hutch does this now, guys. It's blue no matter who, but
like Nazi tattoo, Nazi tattoo, Nazi tattoo, Nazi tattoo. Every
argument he's ever made. Like the vast majority of his coverage
of Graham Platner has been complaining about Graham Platner in
the exact way he complained about all of the uncommitted people
attacking Kl over Gaza and over Israel. It's like the he's followed
every single one of the steps they went
even after giving all of his criticism. And I just don't get
it. I just don't get it. He's just obviously lying about that.
If I lived in Maine, I would support Platner.
If you live in Maine, I think you should vote for Platner. I
think winning a Senate majority is bigger than any one candidate,
even in the most extreme circumstances like this one. What's
worse, a Nazi tattoo or
Well, uh, it's a little bit different talking about like the
Senate here.
>> It's a little Wait, it's a little different. What? And
well, uh, it's a little bit different talking about like the
Senate here, but
>> yeah, it's like talking about who has the Senate majority,
you eggheheaded. Oh my god,
dude. This is so stupid. It's a Senate seat. It's It is It's
critically important. Okay, it's critically
Anyways, they're you know, they're going nuts over this one candidate.
For my whole life, we've heard from establishment slashcorporate
slash >> Also, I'm I'm I'm already becoming furious right
now because
you get to you get to go complain about blue no matter who if
you were blue no matter who.
No,
wrong.
You're trying to get the people who weren't blue, no matter who,
on your side, you stupid. So when you stop entertaining it after
getting them on your side, you look stupid.
How is that hard to understand? You are trying to get people
who were not blue no matter who to be in a blue no matter who.
And then you are flip-flopping on that ideal the first moment
it becomes even a tiny bit inconvenient for you.
It's disgraceful, frankly.
You know what I mean?
If you were actually blue no matter who, then I think you have
you at least you were
If you if you if you haven't been blue no matter who in the past,
I don't think you have any right to be giving this
>> At the end of the day, you have to vote blue no matter
who. Even if you don't like the candidate, even if you know they
disagree with you on one or two issues, even if they're like
big issues, honestly, even if they disagree with you on like
eight or nine issues, um you really have no choice. You kind
of got to suck it up and vote for the Democrat no matter what
because the Republicans are so bad that uh you really have no
choice here. There's Kyle being blue no matter who
based patriot Kyle Kolinsky.
Listen, no matter how bad it is, you got to vote blue. You got
to do it. You got to do it, man. Come on, man. Look, that's a
that's a line of reasoning that I was very very skeptical of.
Namely because it just felt like there are way too many Democrats
who don't actually fight for Democratic policies or what are
supposed to be Democratic policies in the past. Everybody knows
this. I've gone back and forth between voting for Democrats and
voting for third parties or sitting out an election. Um but I
must say that what >> back and forth I mean Okay. Well,
>> watching this MAGA crime >> in this segment where
Hutch is entertaining going back and forth where he's saying,
"Well, don't don't like try to get people back in line who are
falling away from Blue no matter who." He goes, "Oh, Kyle was
back and forth. What an idiot." >> Uh, didn't vote for
Hillary, didn't vote for Biden.
Has he said if he voted for KL? He claims he supported her, which
is that word is doing a lot of leg work. I
honestly
the level of contradiction that Hutch operates in on a base level
is very interesting to me.
Like does he not understand that his job is supposed to be like
getting people to vote Democrat? Like convincing people to vote
Democrat, but he actually just spends all of his time on people
who are like entertaining the idea and who have massive audiences.
Like basically representing some sort of some sort of establishment
Democrat, but in the worst way and least inviting way possible.
like he is just the he is like the essence of of like Democrat
elitism.
You didn't you didn't vote for Hillary. You didn't vote for Biden.
Uh why are you even here? What would you even say you're doing
here? It's like dude work. But did he ever say that he straight
up voted for Kla? I don't even know. truly has sort of opened
my eyes to the wisdom of vote blue no matter who because
I I feel like my hesitancy to do that
really stemmed from a lack of imagination as to how truly evil
and horrific the Republican party is.
Lack of imagination.
Excuse me. Why? You didn't even need to imagine anything. It
It's been really bad. for years. It's been really bad for years
and years and >> I think a lot of people had no idea how
bad this second term would be. Like I think a lot of people are
overwhelmed with how bad this second term is. Like in your wildest
dreams, it didn't seem like it would go this crazy. I'm telling
you, like nobody really thought in their heart of hearts it would
be like this. If it was just a second version like 10% up from
Trump 1, like that's lightweight. You know what I mean? This
is like 10x. This is like 20x Trump won. It's crazy. >> He's
saying things had to get as bad as they've gotten after the 2024
election for him to realize,
okay, the Republicans are actually pretty bad, so I need to do
blue no matter who. Bro, they've been really, really bad for
years. Like once you truly digest that the Republican party is
a fascist terrorist imperialist death cult, and they are, >> you
would do like literally anything to stop them. like anything
and everything from the softest tactics to the hardest tactics.
You can and should do all of that. Okay, [laughter]
>> dude. That's uh that's like bordering that's getting
close to stochcastic stuff, is it not? The hardest tactics and
you should do all of them. It's like he's going to have to he
he if he's smart, he walks that back slightly. Okay, so as I've
gotten older, I understand more where that mindset of like vote
no matter who comes from, right? I used to think it was sort
of stupid blind party loyalty. Now I see it's like oh no I get
it. It's because these are so evil and so insane that to do anything
that even in an ancillary way helps them is atrocious. Okay.
Now
>> some of us have been begging you people to understand
this for years. Some of us have been begging you for years to
understand this. >> Here's the thing though. All of those
people
who said vote blue no matter who and screamed that from the rooftops
for my whole life. The second that leftwing Democrats started
actually winning primaries they immediately abandoned that immediately.
That listen now you want to talk about Hutch just did a little,
you know, self- congratulations. Maybe I'd do a little self-
congratulations here as well and say, "Who told you that the
second somebody won a primary, second a lefty candidate won a
primary, you'd see people pull away." Who said that? That's happening
for sure, 100%. Just be ready for it. Don't even be Don't even
be a little thrown off by it cuz it's going to happen. You just
have to rise above it, okay? You got to be better. So, let's
jump forward and go to where Hutch comes back from the bathroom
>> and he invites Josiah in >> and said,
>> uh, there were a couple of people in my replies yesterday
or the day before about Jake Aenclauss, but there was no D vida.
Um, but yeah, I did spar with some people yesterday. >> Yeah.
So, what what was your position on that whole thing? So, just
for the backstory chat, he again he's a Massachusetts Democrat
American.
Um, and said
like it went beyond kind of skepticism, right? Didn't he say
something al it was pretty strong? >> He said he couldn't
conscient it, right? Couldn't good conscious endorsement. >> Wrong
statement. He said something along the lines of, you know, there
shouldn't >> He said he was disqualified. >> Yeah.
Yeah. There should alen clause. >> Right. About platinum
for for the um for for the Nazi tattoo, I imagine. >> And
uh Yeah. But what was your take on
>> Uh my take is vote blue no matter who applies here.
So if Graham Platner is the nominee I mean he's the presumptive
nominee now he will be the nominee but once he is the nominee
Aenclaus needs to shut the up and get behind him. >> So
be honest Josiah Aenclaus need to shut the up already right like
obviously
Josiah has been arguing that Aenclaus should have shut the up
already. Like you could you could I think Josiah said that you
know Aenclaus could say well I support this other guy in the
primary but I'll get behind the the damn candidate. That would
be the wording right? I support this guy in the primary but I'll
get behind the damn candidate is what you say right? Who thinks
the primary won't go to Platner? Nobody. Literally nobody thinks
that. Everybody knows it's going to Platiner. It's not close.
It's not happening.
>> I think that's bold. I think that's a bold that's a
bold thing.
I I guess like
you know me, I'm I'm I I'll bite the bullet on some crazy thought
experiments for Blue no matter who. But even during the 2024
election when
>> not endorsing Kamla, I didn't really like criticize
her all that much for it. In fact, I I told my chat I like I'm
not going to, you know, the optics of that are like really bad.
Um like for example, would you
first criticize her after it? So let's say there was a >> well
hang on just a just a couple of things right there. So listen
if your if your standard is consistent and listen it's actually
vote no vote blue no matter who with an asterisk. So you have
the same rule for aen claus as you do to lead that's fine that's
consistent. Um I'm so horny for a democratic senate majority
that you know my position was like for example like during the
2024 campaign I supported the uncommitted movement in the primary
trying to pressure you know president Biden and Vice President
Harris to move on Gaza in exchange for their votes. I think it's
perfectly fair to try to leverage your vote in a primary, but
my position was after the primary was over, um, you know, if
you were a Palestinian American, an Arab American, a Muslim American,
um, and you felt that what was going on was Josiah always is
very like prepared because he does his videos all the time. Like
he's always got, it's almost like he's written out talking points
for himself every single time. It's very interesting to listen
to him come on to streams. Like you could tell he's not even
talking to Hutch, he's like convincing Hutch's audience, right?
Like I feel like when he comes on to talk sometimes it he is
talking to the other person but it's like with a set of talking
points that he's ready to convince the audience too. >> Was
a genocide facilitated and funded by the Biden administration
even if he had family members um you know who were impacted by
what's going on in Gaza. I'm I'm not unsympathetic to that but
I think that you should still vote for the Democrats, right?
And so, you know, by my lights here, um, if you are a American,
um, and my you should vote for, uh, you should vote for Graham
Platner. And furthermore, if you're Jake Aenclaus, who is not
just a American and not just a voter, but a Democratic leader
and a congressman, then I think the standard is even higher in
the sense that, you know, you have an even bigger duty, greater
affirmative duty to back Platner if Platner is the nominee. And
had Jake Aenclaw said either in his statement or in his clarifying
statement because he got a lot of from a lot of people including
a lot of centrists like Ron Felcowski of Midas Touch he's no
like you know um hippie liberal or hippie progressive right this
is a former Republican who's the editor-inchief of Midas touch
he even read uh Aenclaus the riot act if Aenclaus had said look
I would prefer Costello in the primary or for Janet Mills to
unsuspend her campaign and come back Um, but I will back whoever
the Democratic nominee is in Maine. I'd be fine with that. But
that's not what he said. And thus my frustration with Aen Clauss,
who I otherwise like, like I've done videos every time Aenclaus
has been on my channel in terms of content of coverage. Um, you
know, it's it's pretty glazing cuz he is an excellent debater,
excellent communicator. He's a veteran. Um, he's basically like
a younger Pete Budajge, probably more moderate than Pete Budajage.
Um, but yeah, he really let me down with this one.
I I understand that. Um especially when the stakes are so high.
Um
>> Okay. Do you understand your own position? The position
you obviously should have had. Okay. All right. >> If there
was Let's let me deise a thought experiment. if if there was
a a more obscure
KKK kind of symbol cuz cuz like the toten conf like I I was familiar
with it but not the wait the the symbol doesn't matter here it's
just are do you agree with the principle
cuz Hutch you've been arguing this principle that it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter what your small petty disagreements
are right and every disagreement by the way even if even if you're
disagree agreement was on segregation.
It's a small petty disagreement to not support or not like get
these people into the party. You should maximize seats. This
is the entire idea behind your pro-segregationist argument. So,
quote unquote, right? That even if they have really reprehensible
views, they should be brought into the party if they can
Like it it's not super wellknown
um as much as like the swastika for example. Um,
>> if there was if there was like a KKK like symbol that
had that was analogous that that was that was known to people
who knew like studied history but not necessarily like the lay
person wouldn't necessarily like bought it and and and a candidate
was discovered to have had one of the same exact situation. You
know, military person got a tattoo at a parlor in Croatia.
Okay, just say if the hutch just the platiner situation, >> you
know, claims to not have known after
>> he this is another thing where like he's trying to drive
home just how bad it is. He he does this quite a lot, right?
There's no reason not to say the platiner situation, but he wants
to say like Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi
Nazi that and again if he wants to if he wants to really die
on this hill that having some principled opposition to a politician
is okay, which is my position.
He wants to die on that hill, then just die on that hill. Just
say that's the position.
>> Whatever. Like literally just one to one same thing.
Can you imagine yourself
tell um like telling a black voter or a black Democrat like railing
against a black Democrat for like I guess my position is like
well I kind of get it in that particular case. I'm not going
to
do >> we have to go through it again. >> You're saying
that if if we had like for example like one or thankfully there
are no emerging segregationist Democrats. I'm happy to entertain
your hypothetical, but even if we were to do this hypothetical,
>> Like you're saying that like let's say like one or two
like segregationist Democrats emerge and all of a sudden they
were competitive in like Nebraska or Missouri. You're saying
that us adding that to like get a Senate majority would be worse
than the MAGA movement right now in terms of like like
it's actually crazy. Senate majority, Senate majority, Senate
majority. Dude, >> I think it would be I think it would
make the the So, if I believed empirically it would help stop
Trump, I would encourage you to vote for them. But we just have
a different uh thought process on the empirics. So the empirics
are that I think and I think so is convinced that allowing segregationist
in the Democratic party would uh like hurt mid to long-term results
in the brand of the Democrats that it would worsen our chances
to
do you guys that like like black civil rights leaders when they
were you know deciding who they wanted to.
So again, Soyel has this position, right, where it's like, oh,
long term, you could think about it. And Hutch could entertain
that position if he likes, but unfortunately for him, there now
is no other way to you either like you should be honest about
what your position is. If you're entertaining the soy pill position,
it should be we oppose Graham Platner because Graham Platner
will hurt this party long term and we will give up a Senate majority
right now. like our chance at a Senate majority, we will throw
it away because bringing Grand Platinum. If you just sit there
and hand ring about it and weigh this guy down or or support
weighing this guy down while not actually taking a strong position,
you're just a
but pick a lane, man. Pick a lane and drive to the basket, okay?
Don't don't sit here hand ringing.
You can't sit here in the middle and go, "Well, I understand
some people wanting to undercut him." But, you know, I guess
I guess I would say vote for him, but I don't want to criticize
people who don't want to vote for him and want to rail against
him, but also all I'm going to talk about are his negatives every
single time he comes up.
Uh-huh. Pick pick a lane, man. Pick a lane.
Okay. We're on this one or this one or this >> Kind of
like
hard on that one. Yeah. >> Well, no. I I kind of get it,
too. I I kind of got it when again Palestinian Americans didn't
want to pull the lever for Biden or Harris. I kind of I kind
of get it with voters uh having their reservations about Graham
Platner. I would kind of get it in the hypothetical you describe.
But again, I think at the end of the day, you know, unless because
here's the other thing too where I would bite the bullet is if
we had actually compelling evidence to believe that Graham Platner
was a Nazi, I would probably have to revisit my Okay, how much
do you really want the Senate majority decide? you know, do you
if Graham Platner is a Nazi and he just has a little D next to
his name, you know, is he really preferable to Susan Collins?
Um, like I would I I don't know if I would be as committed as
I am now. I just, you know, I don't I don't believe that Graham
Platner is a Nazi. I don't think you believe Graham Platner is
a Nazi. I don't think Jake Aenclaus believes that Graham Platner
is a Nazi. And Jake Aenclaus isn't just a voter. Again, he is
a he is a
a House of Representatives member, a member of the Democratic
Party who understands the fight voter who also happens to be
a Democratic leader who leads or is is part of an organization
called Democratic majority and it's going to be very very hard
for us to get a Democratic majority I suppose is possible if
we lose Maine. But Maine is one of the easier gets based on the
current landscape. So again, my standard for Aenclaus like while
I would have more sympathy for just I suppose a random voter
my my position Aenclaus would be sir with all due respect um
you have a duty here to the party in the country and you're not
just a random voter and again if you want to say you would prefer
Costello in the primary because of uh you know Graham Platner's
past the tattoo the comments fair enough but you have an affirmative
duty to the party in the country to get behind whoever the Democratic
nominee is and he has not committed to doing that. And that's
again what >> let's just hope Platiner isn't another Federman.
Well, the unfortunate thing with Federman is that he has a like
cataclysmic brain injury that they put him back in Congress with.
So >> that's why I say, you know, he's not just getting
from Kyle and Crystal Ball and whoever. He's getting from mightest
touch liberals. >> No, no, I Yeah, I understand. No, but
in my thought experiment, could you imagine yourself like telling
a telling a black Democrat to, hey, listen, suck it up. We got
you got we got to take back the Senate. I'd probably try to be
polite about it, but yeah. Yeah.
>> I don't know. >> But again,
I understand. I understand. And listen, fair enough. As long
as you're consistent.
What what I don't with are people again cuz like there were some
people in the in the conversation yesterday and Doss Vidan may
have been one of them who were like, "Well,
when because I use the Kla Harris example, I'm sorry. It's the
shot. It's the shot. You expected Palestinian Americans to set
aside their Yeah. You know, I had a I had a family member blown
apart in Gaza. >> Why is he putting black people on a pedestal?
I don't know. Maybe for a lot of people, I think it's just something
most people understand
how to look at race relations
in a way that like, hey, something's clearly unfair there. It
it does sort of it creates like a bright line for people where
they might not be clear when it's other topics. So, I do understand
bringing it up sometimes because of a war that Biden and Harris
funded and you expected me to pull the the the lever for Biden
and Harris, then yeah, I'm sorry. The the the tattoo is infinitely
less egregious than an actual humanitarian crisis.
[laughter]
Who said that? Who said that it's infinitely less? Who said Yeah.
Okay. Nazi tattoo versus a bunch of kids in Lebanon. Still, by
the way, still still,
wait, that's current support, but this would be about Yeah. versus
the Kla thing, which was still a genocide going on. Come on,
man. Come on, dog. >> Which is being facilitated in part
by the Biden administration. And I did expect Arab and Muslim
Americans to vote for Kla Harris or Joe Biden. Cuz that's the
other thing. Well, Kla Harris wasn't in charge of foreign policy,
so you can't hold that against her. Yeah, but I also had that
standard when Biden was the nominee, too. If you want to use
the uncommitted movement to pressure him in the primary, that's
fine. But at the end of the day, if the choice is between him
and Trump, you I still think you should back Biden. >> I
do think they're different, though. I I I don't I don't think
they're quite the same thing at all. Um
you mentioned it already, but VPs don't control foreign policy.
So, the fact the fact that Kla Harris inherited all that baggage,
I felt
betrayed a kind of like something. >> I'm sorry. >> Was
she also was she against the all the operation? Did she distance
herself? Did she come out and say actually I I strongly disavow
this? She do anything to distance herself or
say that she was it was against like her conscience or anything
or even just take like a a positive stance towards stopping the
>> Did she do any of these things or >> Well, I don't
know if it is I said I said Biden or Harris. >> No, I understand
that. But I'm just saying like the the the logic of blaming Kamla
for what happened in Gaza after October 7th is so flimsy.
>> That's fine. That's fine. I'll grant you. I don't I'm
not I'm not going to circle the drain on this. But then also
but then also but wait just you got to let me talk too. I love
you. You're my >> Well, hang on. But but like I
I I hope these people see this guy. I hope these people see this
guy. He's like the worst. He's actually like just
like a He's just a man. I don't know what else to say. He does
this.
It's It's actually crazy that he does this. Okay. That's why
Josiah is just talking to Hutch's audience. Yeah. Yeah. No, the
you're my boy thing is you are being condescending in a lot of
cases,
right? It's it's it is condescending, but I think I don't think
Petco used it on Hutch that much in person. Maybe he did. I'm
I'm trying to think of if he did or not. It is condescending
though. And right here, I don't know why he would say it to get
him to stop talking. >> Wait, wait, wait. But >> wait,
you got to let me talk, too. I love you. You're my boy. >> Well,
hang on. But but but because we're like Hutch Hutch didn't have
an argument here, right? Josiah literally pre-fired his argument
on Kamla.
And then Hutch is like, "But I'm still going to make that same
argument." He just wasn't listening. Again, by the way, cuz Josiah
already knocked that argument down before Hutch even gave that
argument. Josiah knocked it down and Hutch wasn't paying attention.
We're limited on time. Can you concede that that that excuse
doesn't work for Biden? that Biden was in charge and we still
expected Palestinian Americans to voted to vote for Biden when
he [clears throat] was the nominee. >> Even then, I'm a
little flimsy on it. But like I told you, I I I I did not give
to there were a lot of clips of her popping up on my feed, you
know, on Biden, calling him a genocide enabler. And I told my
chat at the time, I was like, "Listen, I'm not going to lecture
this person. I'm frustrated by this, but I'm not I just I'm just
not going to lecture someone in that spot." Um, but even even
then I I find it kind of flimsy because Biden is not responsible
for how Israel conducted themselves after that war. And uh
then who is?
I'm going to go ahead and say that the leader of the country
providing them aid and weapons and a security guarantee is probably
a little responsible. I I'm sorry. I I hate to tell you, the
United States had some ability to control Israel, to to inhibit
Israel there, and they did not use the leverage they had. That's
just factual. You don't like it, that's okay, but that's just
true. >> Um, you know, it also involved Congress. It was
a bipartisan effort with Republicans as well. But I don't think
it's
I don't think it makes a lot of sense to like blame him for how
Israel conducted themselves. And he his administration did at
many times throughout that time period.
um influenced the Israelis in a positive direction to allow humanitarian
aid into the country to evacuate Rafa before they did that big
offensive. And so I mean you have to be kind of like really read
up on this stuff to understand that which is why >> I think
he did a decent amount to try to
>> without inhibiting Israel significantly
slightly keep things a little more optically safe.
It didn't work and it still went really badly. But he did do
some things.
But you just wouldn't make this argument given where it went
to. I don't think you would ever make this argument. All right.
With other like sets of war crimes, anything like this, I don't
think you'd go, "Well, actually, one time they sent in like cookies
for all the people." Yeah. I don't Does that matter? Is that
like a significant thing? Like cool. They they sent some cookies
in, but then a bunch of people died still. A bunch of people
starved. bunch of people are left without homes or clean food,
clean water or food, >> That's like one of the reasons
why I didn't want to fight him on that. But, you know, it's just
a little it's a little different for me to compare that situation
to a guy who, you know, had a literal Nazi tattoo. And >> yeah,
it's hard to compare them because obviously the Nazi tattoo is
nowhere near as bad. You bald [__]
>> Definitely lied about it. I'm not I I agree with you.
I don't think Grant Platner is a Nazi. I do think that it's
If you don't think he's a Nazi, what is the point of constantly
saying, "He lied about the tattoo. He lied about the tattoo.
He lied about the tattoo."
Do you not understand at all
if Do you not understand at all that when he goes when you go,
"He lied about the tattoo. He lied about the What are you implying?
What are you What are you signaling to
Well, he definitely lied about the tattoo. He had the tattoo
for 15 years and he definitely lied about it and like I I don't
know what what are we supposed to do about that?
>> Come on, man. That he knew that it was a Nazi tattoo,
but but still got it anyways because of the military implications.
Like he just wanted to look like a big bad scary person or whatever.
Um but but he for sure lied about knowing what it was after the
>> Okay,
but you're not concerned. What would be the concern if he was
lying?
You want politicians who never lie, pick a different planet.
Right? I think lying is bad. I think lying over something totally
inconsequential from your personal life is not as bad
objectively. Especially when it's weighed against a Senate seat.
Like come on, man. Right. Especially
it's you're you're talking about a Senate seat. So you could
say all of this. You could say he lied about it. Well, you If
if he lied about it, then what's the big deal? Well, he you know,
he got it not because he's a Nazi, because he wanted to seem
like a big scary military guy. Okay, so what's the problem? Well,
he lied.
All right. What if Dude, there's got to be an example of other
lies like this, right? Other totally totally tiny, minuscule
lies that nobody cares about that Hutch would absolutely defend.
I know this is the case because he's a political operative or
he's a political streamer. He would definitely do this in other
cases. Anyway, we keep going. And I just if I put myself in the
shoes of a person I that would be a really tough pill for me
to swallow. And so for me and I'll finish up here for me. >> Hutch
could you reiterate your core point like four more times so maybe
Josiah understands it or hears it?
You think if you repeat it like a hundred more times maybe he'll
get it? >> Me I think the strat is to just like let that
go. Just let it go. You know, like we can do the m we can push
blue no matter who, but when it comes to like this particular
thing, I don't know if it makes a lot of sense to be like picking
fights with.
>> So, I would just want to know where did Hutch make an
argument?
What is Hutch's argument?
Cuz this is a Nicholas Dioro argument. Well, listen, man. You
might be right, and this could be true. Everything you said could
be true. But it just looks a little weird to tell a guy not to
be mad about a Nazi tattoo. Did you think about that? Did you
think about how it's weird to tell a American not to be mad about
a Nazi tattoo? It's like, yeah, but it's the Senate and it's
the it's the second half of the Trump admin possibly still maintaining
a majority in the Senate.
It's possibly like the most consequential race in the entire
midterms.
Well, sorry, it has the ability to be. Shouldn't be. What it
should be is the entire Democratic party unifying behind Graham
Platner so that they can get control of the Senate, right?
And then the harder races should be elsewhere. But it seems like
Democrats are determined to turn
uh Maine into a difficult seat to win. I don't know why. >> Americans
who don't feel comfortable with this guy. I kind of get why they
don't feel comfortable. >> So So a couple of things here
and again. >> And by the way, nobody's saying you should
feel comfortable with this guy. They're saying you should vote
for this guy and you should endorse this guy.
If you want to say tattoo notwithstanding cuz I find that gross
and I I don't know that we've heard the whole truth there. I
absolutely endorse this person because it's very important that
we that we gain regain control of the Senate. Right. That's all
you got to say, man. It gets a little bit of your little, you
know, thing out there. It gets a little bit of your like disavow
out there, but you still say obviously we need to go ahead and
vote for this guy again. And we're pressed for time. Um, yeah,
I I am not I am not blaming Joe Biden for everything that Israel
did. And I totally agree with you that Joe Biden um used influence
at various points to try to blunt the extent of um of Israel's
crimes against Gaza and the the the ruthlessness of the campaign.
I totally concede that. Now, what I don't concede is this idea
that Biden is totally divorced. I do think that he had agency
and culpability in what followed, and that is a consensus of
the American people. So, you know, whatever the underlying fact
of the matter is, the perception, the widespread perception is
that Biden is partly to blame. Not Netanyahu level, but he is
partly to blame and could have used his position as the most
powerful person in the world to perhaps should firm to try to
blunt that, which you yourself can see. Number one. Number two,
>> again, I I totally understand that it would be a bitter
pill to swallow. I I agree with that. Um, but when I look at,
again, I'm just looking at it from the vantage point of >> Yeah.
So, Josiah is like making points. I I swear if if Hutch listens
to this and says something along the lines of I hear what you're
saying, man, but like Nazi tattoo guy. I just Yeah. What What
are you going to do? I will lose it. I will actually lose it.
Of first a
platner and then a Palestinian American with Biden or >> There's
no way, right? Graham Platner had a Nazi tattoo and lied about
it. I agree with that. What you and I had this conversation.
I even publicly posted um when I got read the riot act about
this and people that for me it was the Reddit thread. Somebody
linked me to a Reddit thread where he was in a sub post under
the toteencom thing where it's just it's it's really hard to
imagine that he didn't know what it was or didn't find out about
what it was after he had it and didn't get rid of it. Right.
versus a Palestinian American who has reason to believe that
the one of the candidates
is facilitating a genocide that's orders of magnitude worse.
Like we would agree with that, right? That having a Nazi tattoo
and lying about it is is is as is terrible but is infinitely
less bad than facilitating or a genocide against your family,
your people. Right? We would agree that those are two wildly
different things,
right? Just from his face. Just from his face alone, just from
his face alone,
you could just tell he's like
Nazi tattoo guy.
Nazi tattoo guy. >> Yes. But again, I take >> Okay.
Wait, wait, wait. There shouldn't There shouldn't even be There
should be no hesitation there. I don't have time to litigate.
I don't have time to litigate that. So, I'll just take the
Fantastic, Moran. There should be no That's just an obvious yes.
That's just an obvious yes. Come on, >> My point is
there's some important there's there's some important caveats
there, but okay, let's go. >> Sure. Sure. Well, and we
we can we can hash that out. >> Of course. Of course. Everybody
in this chat says no, it's not worse. No, it's not worse. Is
there a genocide? If it were a genocide, nope. Nope. Off. No.
No. No. Fantasy. That didn't happen. Nope. It's not a genocide.
[laughter]
Awesome. So awesome, man. You love to see it. You love to see
it. Now I'll I'll pop in on the next episode of Live and Learn
where you can make the case to me that actually Josiah is Josiah
taking lessons from Pisco.
Is Josiah taking lessons from Pisco
in terms of trying to have normal intelligent conversations with
Hutch and failing because he lacks the capacity? >> Yeah,
he's taking lessons from Pisco. Yeah, precisely. Precisely. Thank
you. >> A person who is not a Nazi having a Nazi tattoo
and lying about it is as bad or >> Let's do that. You come
on the next >> We can we can we can have that conversation.
You can explain that to me cuz that one I I'm baffled by that
one. But I'll take your I'll take your reluctant. Yes. My point
is I'm consistent here and you're consistent. That's really all
that matters. You're not having a special rule for Joe Biden
or a special rule for Graham Platner. You're consistent. I get
why a Palestinian American wouldn't pull the lever for Biden.
I wasn't going to wag my finger at Rashida Talib. I'm not going
to do it for Jake Aenclaus. That's perfectly fair. I've got no
smoke for you. Um I do have smoke for people who have the double
standard. And I do have smoke for Aenclaus just on my own lights
because again, he's not just a random voter, a random American.
He's part of leadership. And again, unless you genuinely believe
that Graham Platner is a Nazi and I don't think the evidence
is there, or if you said again, you know, I I prefer Costello
in the primary because he's technically still in the primary.
He's not going to win it, but he's it's it's a possibility, right?
And um I support him and I I back Josiah, please. You're breaking
our hearts. Stop railroading Hutch.
Bro, it's there. Apparently Hutch now has an audience that doesn't
that sees him as like a mental invalid. He He cannot be anything
but railroaded. If if anybody is ever talking and saying something
correct, it's you're actually wrong for doing that. You're wrong.
You're wrong. You're evil. Stop doing that. You know, I'll support
the Democratic nominee at Jay's talk. What do you think is the
real reason Hutch or sorry, Josiah left Live and Learn? He was
smart. Lol. I know what he said. And then I disagreed. I disagreed
that that was the reason.
He said he was just like busy and he didn't have time for it.
And in my head, I'm like, dude, you that's like not a commitment.
That's like such a high value commitment that like it's like
an hour or two a week. And I understand, but realistically, you
could do like one less video, maybe. I think it was I think it
was having the cast come under attack and that he was having
to deal with drama outside of the show that had to do with the
show. I think that's what it was that he was just seeing that
the show was going to be used as like a wedge between this group
of people and he just wanted no part of that. That's what I think.
But he didn't say that. He said he just needed the time back.
So, uh, who am I to tell him he's lying? Man, whoever that may
be, I'm cool with that, too. But that's not what Aenclaus said.
So, I'm I'm very easy to please. I'm not saying that Aenclaus
had to get down on one knee and say, "Yes, sir, Graham Platner.
Um, I will I will I will hold your hand and campaign uh with
you in Maine." And that's not what I'm asking for. I'm just asking
as a leader of of the the coalition trying to get a Democratic
majority in the Senate, um that he just say he's going to back
the Democratic nominee, whoever it is. And if he wants to state
a preference for Costello, that would have been fine. That's
it. >> All right. All right. All right. We are going on
to the next time stamp. >> So people are calling this guy
an Israel first Democrat. And I think that's fair. >> I
mean that's not even a subtle anti-semitic trope there. Move
to Israel, Jake. Telling a American Israel playing into like
a a decadesl long trope of dual loyalty. Like not even a subtle
anti-semitic trope at the end >> Move to Israel, Jake.
So people are calling this guy in >> an abundance, bro.
Oh my goodness. Get him out of here. Send him to Israel. Israel
first Democrat. And I think that's fair. I think that's fair.
In fact, uh, he's taken a colossal >> I think it's fair
to call him an Israel >> colossal amount of money from
the Israel >> Bro, he literally he fought in Afghanistan.
This is a veteran, a military veteran
that he's accusing of being Israel first. Like they don't they're
not even I don't think Kyle is an anti-semite, but holy. How
about this one? Throwback to when Jake Alen Claus was in hot
water for old Facebook post about burning the Quran. Look at
this. I'm sorry for 20110 Facebook post about burning the Quran.
>> Wait, are we using are we using old social? I just need
to be clear on the rules. Okay. Are we using old social >> Well,
you can't do that. He said this on Twitter already. This is one
of his Twitter bangers. Oh, are we going to use social media
post to cancel people? >> Post to disqualify people. >> No,
it's to look at his beliefs, right? I think Graham Platner will
say what he does and doesn't believe. I guess you'd have to look
at a Claus and say, "Well, what does he believe here, right?"
>> Yes or no. Because if we're doing that,
boy is this awkward in the context of this conversation. >> Boy,
is this ever awkward. Also, um >> I never looked into the
full actual post of this. >> I'm sorry for 2010 Facebook
post about burning Quran.
>> I was told to actually look at the post for this.
Um facing mounting criticism from his Democratic primary rivals,
Newton uh city councelor Jake Aenclaus on Wednesday formally
apologized for a decade old social media post alluding to burning
the Quran. Aenclaus, who is who was viewed as a front runner
in the race to replace Congressman Joe Kennedy, wrote in a 2010
Facebook post, "So we can't burn their book, but they can burn
our flag." He linked to an article about Pakistani lawyers earning
the American flag initially described the comment as a sarcastic
remark he made uh
this stop short of apologizing
his rivals pounced blah blah blah blah I mean it's not like not
terrific but
>> based on >> we will get to this I'm trying to
figure out what do I want to put in the middle of these things
I think I'll do some clips here real quick but I will I will
want to put something in the middle of Hutch before we get into
the Hutch review of all of this okay uh yo Dickers Thank for
the raid on kick. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I see you covered the the Connor stuff today. We're going to
go over the Hutch review of that >> Done the reaction.
I was I I was expecting much much worse. Okay, >> we're
doing some politics. So this guy, who actually is in league,
by the way, when he does like this, sorry, it's true, but you're
in league with white supremacist and Nazis. Okay, you did >> Careful
now, Kyle. Careful. Careful. >> But Platner's tattoo is
unacceptable. Number one, even though he got it covered up. Number
two, even though it was a skull. >> Even though he got
it covered up. Holy [__] man. I the whole Platner
this whole Platner arc I just feel so gaslit by these people.
Oh, you think having a Nazi tattoo for over a decade and only
getting it removed right before a new story came out about it.
You think that's bad? What about a old Facebook post from 2010
where you said uh something about burning the Quran because somebody
was burning an American flag? Oh my god. Okay. >> He didn't
realize was a Nazi symbol. Okay. Number three already for it.
>> read the tweet. Israel first damn.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
>> Oenclaus, hello. What was that? That was a primer for
Reuben Rubin. Thank you so much, Reuben. Ruben, for the primer.
Oenclaus led a letter to Rubio in September calling US allies
to who recognized Palestinian statehood performative and calling
on the Trump admin to work against them. His pack is a primary
backer of McMorro even though Stevens was on his letter. And
Angie Craig, weird guy.
Sounds like a weird guy. I don't think it's weird to call him
an Israel first dem based on based on that. Really? >> He
crossed a line whereas you everybody should forgive you. Of course,
right. No joke. There we go. >> There's no way he's being
serious right now. There's no way. There's no way he's being
serious about like a Facebook post from a 22-year-old in 2010.
Specifically that Facebook post is worse than getting a Nazi
tattoo. It's still It's just so absurd. It's so absurd. You kind
of have to laugh at it. It's kind of funny. Like it is it's kind
of funny. This whole This whole situation is just like it's like
a It's like a It's like a Saturday Night Live skit. I don't It's
just uh he's taken $915,000 from pro-Israel packs. So that's
the real reason why he's against Grand Platter. If Grant Platter
had the same tattoo, he was pro- Israel, Jake Alouch would be
endorsing him no problem whatsoever. No questions asked. None.
>> Why would you just assume that? That's a crazy thing
to assume. I do feel like we're kind of diving into some anti-semitism
here. Is it okay to say that? This feels anti-semitic uh to make
these kinds of assumptions. Uh but since he has that >> I
don't think Hutch is intellectually equipped to discern that
based on him looking up all that person's statements and and
not understanding any of them. I just actually think he's like
fundamentally he's at an IQ deficit. He is too low IQ to really
make the determination at any point in time. He does that cuz
he's he's uh dancing for scraps right now. You know, he's he's
jiggling the he's jingling the jar. Give me a couple bucks, guys.
Come on. Isn't this anti-semitic? Come on. and puts some money
in the jar. Put some money in the jar.
>> Or he did in the past, doesn't anymore. Uh, and he's
critical of Israel because of their genocide. Well, that now
it's unacceptable. Now I'm going to do an effective endorsement
of Susan Collins. Are you kidding me? Now, >> effective
endorsement is doing a lot of leg leg work here, >> by
the way. Yes.
No, it's Does he not understand effective endorsement is when
you say something's doing a lot of leg work, you you point to
the adjective effective or something would be what's doing the
leg work there. If you wanted to make that, you can't say the
whole thing. You can't say the entire thing is doing a lot of
lifting. When you say that, it's saying that one. You're hiding
all the complexity of the issue behind like one term like effective,
right? That's what you mean by it's doing a lot of heavy lifting.
It is your entire argument is is summed up by the one word you're
using. You can't take the whole statement and say it's doing
heavy lifting. No, that's their whole statement. He continues,
"As I said months ago, I find planners not tattoo in his commentary
about it personally disqualifying. If it were me, I'd vote for
someone else in the main Democratic primary. He's He's the nominee.
It's over. It's done. Regardless of what >> that didn't
stop whatever >> happens to me. Democrats need to
>> Yeah, but do you which side do you want to be on? Kyle
is on your side now. Kyle started this video off by saying I
understand blue no matter who. It's weird that these people don't.
And now instead of saying right, Kyle, this guy should be blue
no matter who. You're going Kyle, don't you remember how you
were blue no matter who? That's how Kyle started the video off
saying I reallyed up and I'll keep it. What a sick joke. What
a sick joke. So I said resign. people are uh showing here. Look
how much money you've taken from the Israel lobby. And this is
why you'd be comfortable with Susan Collins and not with Gran
Platter because he's not taking any money from the Israel lobby.
Uh Ron Filicowsky says, "You said his tattoo is personally disqualifying
and I hope Maine voters agree with me. One, there are two choices
in the race. Two, the race could decide the Senate. Three, your
statement will be in lots of GOP ads. It already is, by the way.
It already is. Four, nobody in Maine wants anyone in Massachusetts
to tell us what we should do." Shout out to Ron Philip, man of
Minus Hutch. He's awesome. Where where is what does Hutch have
for disagreement here? Like like okay Tommy Vtor, Ron Philipowski
and Richard Hanania really running the gamut here all agree that
this is an endorsement of Susan Collins. Why does this bald not
agree? What does this bald see that these actually respected
political commentators don't? Did somebody help? >> Awesome.
Uh Tom, have you called her mil to discuss it? Talking about
you haven't even talked to planner. You're just endorsing against
him. I wonder why that is. Could it be because you take a gazillion
dollars in Israel lobby money and he's critical of Israel and
critical of genocide and you support genocide? Is that why? Is
that it? Is that something to do with it? You die at maga prick.
>> Oh my god. All right. I think we're done with that.
God damn it, man. >> No. No response. Zero response.
>> And then people say like, "Well, Kyle's on the team
now." Well, is he though? I don't. That seems dubious to me.
>> These are all people who are on Well, sorry. Tommy Vtor
and Ron Philowski are on the team. Yes. The team is calling this
stupid.
Why are you not on the team, Hutch? The entire team is calling
this stupid, man. Wake up.